[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
hear you man welcome to the show if you
foreign
[Music]
hear you
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
what's going on guys you should be able
to hear everyone fine Cog is still
the process of getting
he was doing stuff
we got everyone else here we're just
waiting for God
here's the melody or what
[Music]
creation that will call upon your allies
call them call your allies call violas
I demand you to come out
all your allies
are new to
YouTube is over to me
[Music]
the banner of Courage yeah what's that
you have to press X while you're here
rally on me
on me
if you want my garlands to stop
following you use your banner again to
ask them to stop
all right is that is that better smooth
[Music]
you can also use the banner to send your
friends in any direction you want send
them over to action go baby Golem
hey we go
go get a baby Golem
s
[Music]
we're going they got the fake piglets so
you can kill them
[Music]
is terrible so we created some full
break them down
foreign
[Music]
and I put laxative in all they water
what games
running out your mouth
yeah it was Mortal that's right all the
freaking uh the Orcs
that's right this one
all the tutorial is complete it didn't
take long it's a very simple simplistic
game
foreign
look at that HDR
I wonder if they got the ray tracing
enabled
[Music]
come on guys rally up on King
all right so okay so got the four yeah
[Music]
all right so
four of you in the chat
I need four of you I see you in there
kiss move I'm gonna use you guys to
volunteers tribute in place
oh Jesus
tell me what just gonna do campaign
I have no idea to be honest yeah I don't
know I only know this is
I can check though
[Music]
where am I supposed to go to The Well of
Despair well this
I hope you're feeling okay
oh you ain't on a well of Despair yet
there's no telling what you're facing
the Overworld now that the piglets come
on little peoples so the sooner you move
I need four people guys
head over to action and we'll get
started
okay I think I did the tutorial
I got the whole village with me
and that's where the elas come in play
the right Melody on your loot and
they'll get almost made it into the well
of despair
[Music]
in no reason to go through the will of
Despair
and I find more people on my my quest
the piglets are Relentless let's go
y'all I got the whole Squad oh I just I
just hurt myself
the whole thorn in the street watch out
is this The Well of Despair [__] don't
get the impression that OG Minecraft
yeah this is buried yeah I'm not
supposed to be on in this playground
you have no idea how wrong I feel being
here right now
my avatar is 12.
I don't want to play with the games
let's go and play with the King
little piglets
you're alone oh God no
Warriors or some paint today that's
what's up
I said laxative in the water each spot
out a whole bunches
go up I think so
that's right let's keep these fires
burning we don't need no water let them
how much you got
it
almost twice for that 100.
104 000.
yeah
shut your mouth
in reality but I have like 82 or
something like that yeah we're we're all
at Dreamcast Cloud
shut up yeah you want to pull up the
pull up that
gcasks
my first console face get up out of here
I'm done so about what's your game of
score King ask your mom yo you stupid so
that's why game of score in the arcade
though for sure
me and your mom's just playing
My Double Dutch skills is crazy
chat
I like the fact that we got to get the
pigs
whose idea was that genius
um back sometimes you need a nice check
in after smashing your face against
Grand Masters
lucky sitting back at 5 000 this game of
school
as I must ask we get moving oh
all right
well that structure be
sure
she's in my room watching something on
TV
no that's the point
yo I can see how this is is for those
dudes and you know the laid back smoking
cigars yeah relaxing you mean you mean
children
now you got grown man swear by this
hey man
the world of despair
it might expose you to user generated
content that made out of suitable for
all ages
[Music]
I come see my wood dude
I think we can have a couple people in
here because it looks like there's room
on that thing though it's smooth
oh they got me riding so I'm I'm in the
game hold on just join into it foreign
he's in another region
Let Me Ride My Horses
[Music]
oh they got the little sheeps can I kill
the sheeps
oh there you go okay
y'all see me I'm black as hell okay
what the hell
anymore
no this is just the world map yeah
freaking following you keep Landing in
these thorns yeah
I grab people as I go along
hey
that's where our camera's off
so even if you don't send out your
little things to to get uh what you
would call it to get wood and stuff you
collect just as you walk through things
bro
all right
Somebody almost killed me taking damage
yeah what's going on over here
oh man somebody pulled me back this
tethering crap yeah it's tethered always
tethering oh it is
not me yeah shout out to Redford no
chance of me
I don't know where you at we went yeah
that wasn't me I'm not the one I think
Saul was ahead of us I don't even know
what's up I'm at the Village I'm at you
at the Village
right now don't forget how did I kill
you
might as well own us you hung us
wow wow
fires
oh hell
I'm getting trees
we're getting all we're still in all
they trees they don't got trees those
are our trees
yo I might get hurt okay yo watch out
for what's on the floor is it the rose
thorns that be out there
and some of the stuff got um the stuff
that killed us the last time it was acid
on the floor
don't care about our well-being
yeah
yeah yeah you probably you brought us
straight into hell that's all right
Welcome to Hell I got it I got a team
generator
y'all gotta see the Pope's Exorcist
they go attic they go
my girls can't sleep
[Music]
you gotta open up the gates
Mario Brothers
yeah we did it that's it it's a wrap
stay out
I'm sorry we show up right now after
they don't did all the work this is
whack
[Music]
that's where we were
yeah you'll see us there it says you're
close you're close
back up
full of free what's going on we are here
okay
[Music]
all right we got to build the carpenter
Hut
did you cancel it stop that
just stopped it
thank you
but it's so smooth
who are you murdering why are you
murdering the town folks what are you
doing now I ain't worried in no time for
what I did was solver got a whole army
with him
got the baby Golems
Leaf the water from those again
the Lake of the spears over here
look mounting an attack on another
Village
everybody
songs literally got all the Army we
can't get anything we can't get no Army
wait hold on wait wait hold up it's
shared yeah that's shared resources
like literally the whole Army and we
just come in there alone
I guess I'll do what I'm able to do
that's just collect resources get okay
can I can I get some resources I guess
so can I kill them off
don't worry about it
Forte shout out to these grown men
playing Minecraft
on the playground
us hey Kitty hey guys hey guys hey guys
that's definitely a hey guys hey guys
oh what's this I found a question mark
oh touch that oh okay oh why you left
that dope it's cold as hell over here
man another Village is it our hero my
nipples
that's why I have to play Forever you
gotta skipping the cinematics
let's close that door it's cold as hell
attack I'm attacked what are you doing
what you did
y'all
did we save it already chill ready oh
wow okay dreams are gone the piglets are
gone
thank you too go to the Village chest at
the basement
[Music]
they ain't doing nothing
except the song Saul got the Army I
ain't helping loses
it's supposed to be a team effort here
[Music]
take all these turns we got that
imminent music
songs took the whole Army so we gotta
have Turtles to help us fight
um
so we're putting these towers up do we
even know what direction they're coming
I don't think you guys
so you used a d-pad pause to go uh
you can use a d-pad if you want
you got to go to you gotta go to the
building part use your right bumper left
bumper to go back it says Arrow Tower
yeah carpentero
it's the Penguins
[Music]
will attack from all sides
you have the Army you're not welcoming
where are the Penguins
[Music]
[Applause]
charge
they got that beef music
join me animals of the forest today is
the day you rise up
the Mad Aztec warriors
oh there they go
wow today is the day
you died in hell
today is the day we fight and they die
all the rabbits
hold him
oh so you've got the real army and we
got the Adam arm relax go
all made it to another Village I like
the beach music
[__] them
everybody
where'd the other ones go turtles you
attack it's like you put yourself alive
double go down and then for me
today's the day we find out that animals
are useless
remain
I said our piglets are friendly
oh why are you stupid
The Invasion has been repelled
thrilled that you defended their
Fountain and we played in the Rockets
villages
be the little girl right now
congratulate us for helping with the
villages
you guys are not wanted here
somebody touched my strawberry there's a
piglet Outpost who's supposed to destroy
you have to go oh yeah
on my way
time to battle the pigs
get the fuzz
onward tomorrow
88 hold your head
Teddy up
for all my Bronx people that have dealt
in various things the police is here
stupid
all right
climb any mountain
oh what's this I'm at Jagged Edge Peaks
yeah you see this this ballot is wild
yeah yeah it does have that oh Minecraft
adventurous thing where it's like just
massive lands
yes yes
where is the strawberry princess
I'm here to plunder
barbarians do not co-signs
oh yeah
why are they making us go to this
Outpost that is mad out of the way like
it's bad you need to defend this area
that nobody lives
they send the emissaries
yo I just went through like five biomes
right now
okay I think I am King a Village attack
could happen any moment
attack Could Happen anywhere now
I think I'm over here
well then you beat me cause I I'm still
ongoing what's good yeah I went through
all these mountains
you hopped over the mountains yeah
because you know that's the only thing
we really have to contribute right now
my bad
oh what's this all right I made it to
thunder
you're stupid yeah serious it's gonna
say when you get the watch
I'm in the dry Savannah
who's this sovereign
[Music]
what's up
oh snap that's sovereign
[Music]
[Applause]
the Golem yeah I see your people but how
do I stop from being shot by the arrow
thoughts
I'm going I'm going to the other right
now
so we're taking care of business
yeah
it's great tasty Crush gel
get out of here we make holes in teeth
she looks mad sister
yeah
[Music]
there's no time to waste
this Outpost is done it's booty here
come across the booty
we all have the right
I don't care about anyone sorry no one
cares about the story we have piglets
pillows
adventurous
[Music]
swine is not good for you
filthy slime
that's that
quiet propaganda
[Laughter]
he had in these Hills
chill why is the place called The Nether
that's right called the nether
oh yeah
oh yeah there's something going on yeah
the day you will learn pigs
in a pecking order
now we know who attracting us
they were like five pigments hiding on
the other side
son
smoke is giving freely
[Music]
Lord King what shall we do with all the
Corpses
[Music]
they're delicious
but King we are vegan
you gotta see how quickly
where you at yo you went to another one
by yourself
[Music]
oh here come here
oh my God
you gotta you gotta go off the lake of
this the lake over there
attic is inside how did you make
something that's bad all right here we
go attic built the bridge all right
I'm coming I'm coming I'm coming at it
I'm coming I'm inside yeah
we're done with this Outpost
s
all right
outposts yourself
this is Sparta okay I think it's this
way all right I think it's this way
that's lava
yeah I gotta build this uh Bridge yeah
we can't go straight through like that
nah we gotta watch them call it man
fight
[Music]
top it off hop over you make it that's
why I'm the bridge that attic made
what bridge did he make I don't see
nobody
all right let's talk about the hot lava
all right I'll move on this side and my
gollum's gonna die no come on let's go
well I think I found a way to get over
here I'll help you oh I can't get in
it's just me and you Kings they can't
get it hold up they closed the gates
around you hold on I'm trying to break
this gate down hold on
let's go
break it
yo they locked y'all in yeah I'm on the
outskirts
I'm right at the gates V I'm at the
gates
oh they tried all right
I see them yeah
they smart enough
they're tired from Battle yo these gates
are bad strong
foreign
[Music]
okay
yeah oh they try to somebody please pass
me the bacon knife
pigs in a blanket figs in a blanket I
got resources over here yeah I want to
take that
Army
yeah Microsoft we have to fix this
cannot have this one person
are you distributed them
that's the thing just just I guess don't
because
he spawned a bunch we just hired the
ball and you all working for me
kill him in the bushes kill them in the
bushes ah bacon
[Music]
fresh cut bacon meat
balls
your sword is only for slicing swag
your sword has a particular yeah
apply the right pressure and even the
tallest tower will fall apply the right
pressure
imagine if king would have said that say
that sentence King what would you have
said
apply the proper pressure
yes
tell us what to do here because this is
uh open the map
come over here and take a bath first
chili and la lava
wow
to go to the map return to the will of
fate
over here okay
oh fast travel oh I did it okay
yeah pressure select oh yeah
there goes the tethering
it just takes you to the uh what should
we call it to the uh to the cutscene go
ahead and turn the pages
play The Melody great now go ahead and
build your own now go ahead and build
your iron Improvement see this is where
you lose me oh you did all beautiful
this is where I don't want to play
I Don't Care
she lost me long time ago
what plane this has told me that I need
to buy two copies of this one for my
niece one for my nephew because they are
going to fight him something I know it
the piglets
word I'm trying to get them my sister
doesn't want to baby no little man in
that house she's like no little guy yeah
they got switches I'm like
yeah I'm like trying to shut down the
joy yeah
he picked up she picked her side early
no Xbox is in this house
let's destroy this new type of piglet
Outpost and then we'll play something
else
good god let's go
oh this one out here okay piglet let's
go
oh [__]
onwards to why
follow me everyone
I'm going to the piglets those y'all
presses
yeah precious what do you guys want to
jump on like fortnite or something
before
all right
[Music]
ain't nobody turning that console on
it
that Street Fighter though oh
yeah but I got I got my uh
the full Gaga
I got my Saturn VC controller ready to
go that's oh my God
so what's this
you mean to tell me
I could have made it here
literally traveling like 10 biomes right
now I'm still trying to get to this
oh a cheap man
ride ride the ride train spent two
minutes
a speed weeks
hold on
[Music]
I said In the Heat of battle
all right
there we go
hold on I got it
I don't know the rap so these pigs can
go through wait don't go the way you do
masses
thank you
yes now you could go
it feels different here
and we're losing people like crazy
I'm up here in the middle of the drama
but they
coming with my speed
oh these new piglets have like some
armor on oh well
I said where is King
I'm lost and Never Never Land
never to get there
oh
Jesus
set up a mind thing to get some
Copperstone
not enough
drop this Tower
these suckers keep coming I don't see
anything
[Music]
yes all right let's go on to the next
one
protect us not enough resources to do
anything
I don't like to share resources things
yeah the resources I don't like the fact
that one dude controls the whole goddamn
on me
[Music]
well considering salt is losing that
armor
yeah they they kind of murdered me right
now
and the freaking the arrow towers are
doing the end yeah the hours I was doing
crazy
let's go
oh yeah
should I get the wrong kind of ad I
don't feel like he's not doing nothing
yeah I'll see him doing AJ he's a water
shooter
you build water buses
you got peoples here that they can't be
with nobody
I see people say I've accounted for
[Music]
me for a second I want to show you
something
there's people's over here that nobody
rocking with they ain't got no friends
right here you can't grab these these
guys right here
come with me no they're for Saul oh they
got stuck oh they got stuck yeah your
people's there you don't know how to
Rally them
no yeah no they were with me they got
stuck trying to cross and then I just
crossed another way
bring them addicts
okay we try they but they're loyal to
you they collect their dying field team
oh they're still over though
I got I gotta tell these dudes to go
attack go you go attack go over there a
bunch of people
can't attack destruction yourself yeah
I'm standing next to your people so
ready
hahaha
come get your people
[Music]
my glory said
it sounds good
if they could somehow allow like the
resource booked a little bit I think
when it comes to the multiplayer yes
just to kind of throw that forget about
balance just make it as fun as possible
yeah
[__] why they spit that water like that
what are they doing
that water
crazy
they're just shooting away but the
piglets are dead yeah
break it
so very strong
yep you need at least eight of them dude
[Music]
all right
okay what else do we have to tear down
here let's go sit down in the house
y'all
they said I'm guarding them
on King David
let's go guys
yeah
instead of like I don't like to share
regression I can't stand
yes no reason for it just go go ham and
pardon the puck go ahead
wow you have to find the source of this
magic find it here we go
fortnite here we go bye
well I think I gotta download that yeah
that that makes two of us no problem
until you show up
finally The Rock has returned you bestie
yeah let's go to the uninstall screen
first
it's it's not for me
nothing wrong with it I think it's it's
good but I don't think you ain't lying
towards us
yeah
you're not lying sir
I think the people that love Minecraft
are going to go are going bonkers for it
all right everybody in the chat
we should play MLB the show that's what
we should play
how long is it you think it's going to
take us to download the game like how I
know you're not alone that fast they got
Superior internet yeah it shouldn't be
too though
they'll be here soon
unless it has like a million freaking
updates
2 42.
and it just depends lower speed and you
won't go to uninstall after you install
this today
42.22
what do you guys download a second I'm
curious
uh we have right now depending on where
I am I'm getting 550 megabits per second
ah
house look at that like us
here like we think that's that's not
real please
I will say that I've been really looking
at the streams ever since I moved to
this new location and I will say the
internet here is more stable who's
better I haven't had a stream drop out
since I'm in here that's what's up
[Music]
this is mine completes in about eight
minutes
we're going in right now we will be in
right now
ready up attic yeah is that girl Jesus
[Music]
had spread them gay yeah that's beastie
yeah
we can't see you can't see Daryl doing
this though
for them dances the bastardization of
this character
people complain that they they didn't
like seeing um cradles to it
hey
join in with me
come on
x button
that was that whack Dance come on come
on get in get in at it come on y'all
playing no build though right
yeah
come on
I gotta have the only whack
know where we're going don't act like
you don't know
how to put in work jerks
so I'm stupid
[Music]
yeah buddy
I heard you want some beat pause Coco
stop playing man don't try it no no not
what I'm playing fortnite now come on up
press that up
me
now you about to get this work
here we go one down
it's okay you are flying you are flying
in on what is that a horse
oh the God is in the building and that
roach oh yeah
you like my roach okay
I Feel The Hating Ass
the kid Gonna Go Far
I'm coming at it
because I've been fighting ever since
all right
you got dudes that's coming in the back
side
oh
he dropped him
oh he's gonna kill me
I'm coming my fault
I don't know how you're gonna I got you
man oh God and them don't worry man I'm
here
I don't know what they're about to get
they're about to get a whole bunch of
Kings
who got you
pretty good
who did that to you
white boy Hatcher I won't hatch a dead
so it was a white dude in the Hat
here they go you shot my friend
shot my friend
oh God
it's another dude behind me
Oh
I thought I was gonna hit the water
there was another dude hit me from
behind oh
how close do you guys
go back to the Lafayette
20 I'm halfway 22 gigs they're almost
good
you gotta go back to the lobby you're in
the match
this video
the unbeatable Duo
[Music]
in the club doing these moves
hold my hand
s
hold my hand at it come on
[Music]
don't go make me wanna do what
what's funny is he doesn't consider this
a pause moment
yeah at all yeah
[Music]
I got somebody booted about it
[__]
everybody
who's dead who is that
attic who's that that you got
yeah
there we go
they don't play wait till you see me get
a hold of that Titan
um Attack on Titan again
I got something around my waist that is
Swing me all over the place
y'all see it
oh I got a sword off rip without feeling
that roots with a balloon attack
right there oh disgusted
now he's slowing down like yeah he
looked mad glossy too yeah like a big
balloon roach dropped him
killed him
attic you gotta do this on your side now
thank you
dumbass
yummy
you big dummy
[Laughter]
you're a big dummy
to that guy King got nothing
you got blood in your snow
and I'm a dance on you wanna see me
dance Tanya ah
[Music]
the workout hits a little bit
all right wow really at it you just
gonna really just all right let's go
thank you
he gave me a pistol because
he thinks well that's that's what I
still love
to take the pistol you cry baby
no you're good
oh
oh thank you attic
he knows he stole
he knows there's a sword down here if
you need one
all right I'm in
all right cool
as soon as we finish this we go get you
after the Stream
something cool what's happening this
wasn't bad
oh something cool oh
he's like back inside the whole damn
streams
[Music]
when you tell somebody to send fast
coming to you like now but not now like
yeah
just relax enjoy yourself
me and my girl don't play that we gotta
talk when we get home nah you're gonna
tell me
[Applause]
we gonna talk out to the street bro we
go
it's three ending right now yo they hit
the thing they know we here
[__] them
foreign
[Music]
hmm
I'm turning louder
all right let me see if I can see
sovereign
invite you to the party I invited you
did you see it yeah
I mean
some of us here with the default skin
yeah
very default how long you got uh it says
it's finished but then it says
finishing things up
like now it's like it did the download
a little bit to get some
I'm moving though it's like stuck
[Music]
oh
where do I need to go like expression
okay
I think it's done now now it's done
some access token there
[Music]
you ready what's going on
[Applause]
bee box can be touched directly from
this game no thank you I did not get my
money you gotta let Bill get his bag
[Music]
why do I have the feeling that after
playing this I'm gonna have it
downloaded I just have a feeling I don't
know why
to have this feeling yeah I just feel it
I don't know
I got a cinema with people on bikes you
know what I gotta do lizards on bikes
with Jack I'm gonna hypnotize you so
is there any other sort of default
deal with it
yeah you got to get your clothes game up
now I saw him look at you looking at my
character yeah I'm looking at this
character right now
jackets
[Music]
doing right now you know what's crazy
you know you Gen X you don't know any of
these characters
are you watching the intro yeah
[Music]
no
some stick with rabbit ears
are they sunset overdriving on some the
cinema is very expensive yeah it is
that a lot of the peoples
here they're probably already passed
away oh these people
okay all right so somebody if I I think
I'm a status
all right let's do it at the same time
King let's do it at the same time
hurry
two or at least he got stuff a circle
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
everybody let's ready up
I'm assuming it just plays like a third
person shooter for the most part there's
no buildings
hmm
but I got the Boogie bikes
oh wow
yo he got white oh sorry yeah did I have
that music
the um what you call it
yep they said let me see you Tootsie
Roll I can't yeah
all right
we go ahead and lonely
the violation of Norman
goodbye oh y'all jumped off already yeah
yeah
oh
I got this
foreign
can you guys see what I'm on
I'm not following King I got the I got
the that's the light for puka the Silver
Surfer
I got my board to be my board
I'm on a dragon
Magneto's so far behind okay man I'm
surfing man you gotta let me surf baby
ha ha ha ha ha
[Music]
it's fine
I'm all about this boy that's the game
for me exactly just let me dive into
place let me serve it that's it
it's fine you know the way sir the
moment drops down
yeah okay
I paid my bucks for that one
be the surfing that was fine
how come I got this silver Hatchet where
the guns at all right come on all right
the Cog is down at the bottom [__] I see
you over there but I can't stand oh they
don't guys
oh
I'm out here with a pickaxe I'm about to
get yeah what's good with this picture
get to the guns they got no guns I can't
scale the mountain in this
come here you go the wrong way bro all
right I'm going towards your arrows you
know arrows okay okay
I do a high jump I can't pull up who are
you shooting
you saw somebody
that's hilarious
oh they shooting
in the face
[Music]
if I need to get inside the house
grab them
all right how do I switch to the uh
Silver Surfer with the toast
with that
dropped him who's down me that's me
pick him up
at it pick him up okay I am
about this stop moving
somebody come to your house
got my first kill
yeah
yeah you don't know about this
it gives it that he said what you know
about what you know about it
[Music]
what are we doing what we doing at [__]
man that's the Goku guy y'all like
what's this storm thing what y'all doing
you gotta drink this stuff at your son
get out of here stop get out of here
right there bro how do I get it
right here
oh yeah I got the [__] I got the [__] I
got it down I think so I got it I gotta
use it
how you use it why
uh to uh drink X yeah pull over it pull
your guns out
press y to put put pull out you got it
and then press y to drink it so move it
on you gotta move the left and right
there you go you gotta yeah yeah like uh
right oh press good to shoot okay
Shake shake the lake all right so we
have saw a pig who has no Shields
come here
everybody comes close to me hold on a
second I got a shield potion
okay
all right this is default he don't got
no guns come next to me
all right cheers
y'all all stay here
your plastic you're having your hands
off okay
here you go
he needs more Shields
right so it's Shields right here I got a
small Shield potion how do I drop it for
him
right here
pick it up now drink it
right trigger there you go drink it
you can only get to level 50 with it
drink it again
right now
throw it
of course
oh right here pick out your pickaxe come
here I'm in here in the storage check
out your trick ass and break that
that's how you break structures right
you press wide you take out your pickaxe
oh and and you um
if you bring your guns out now you need
a gun saw I got a shotgun and I got a
sniper right here all right good so
there you go
they already uh they over there
I marked it
down to the chicken oh we're being shot
at
no that was that was chickens
yo can I jump on my surfboard if I fall
off a highway no only if you have aerial
list only if you have aerialists is a
perk so you guys see that your perks
thing is gonna open up and you're able
to press right on the d-pad to pick your
perfect you got to pick the perks when
they come up all right so it's gonna say
perks available attic watch out people's
head and then killed the boss so they
got the heavy power weapons
all right we got a guy coming in
how you do the duck down he's got the
Oni gear all right it's a right bumper
right right
I don't know I hear him use the Oni gear
though
nah that's not throwing me
down
whole team was here
to be
[Music]
another shot coming
all right please
always better okay well I gotta use the
sniper there wow you don't have to use
the snipers there's guns all over the
place
there's one more guy that's out we don't
know where he's at
his boy
he probably ran
no Ray I'm assuming gray is whack right
yeah gray is an average correct
I mean it's better than Gray he's over
here in the back Mark him
dude
oh it's purple
all right so there was over here they
made it into the safe
they didn't open it though
they didn't open it who has the key card
not an epic cash did anybody see a key
card on on the floor anyway no
put these who these little people for
the bosses oh the boss is still up
they're here
who are these random NPCs
[Music]
oh
I'm hot at the house
computer
crew today
[__] oh this dude's still running around
you got the key card guy open the door
oh you dropped the key
I got it
come on we got Shields downstairs come
on
follow me everybody
level up
shut up
oh Jesus
yeah
yeah Auto bunker what the hell is that
so that's slurp juice
and gives you what you call it
um
all right so anytime you use the slurp
juice know that you're gonna get Shields
and help
let me get the shot piece
see that golden guns those are the ones
that uh oh yeah yeah
sophistic shoddy
yo we gotta go the blue is on us so it's
the closest closer let's go let's go
okay that's what that's what that is
yeah that's this we gotta get out of
here
oh these are purple girls
oh
good stuff
they ain't got no [__] gas though I
need to get oh there we go
okay guys here we go
the island is getting ready to show up
the island showed up where's the island
at though
300 and some odd miles away
uh everybody up here where I'm at we're
gonna use the springboard the spring
towards the island
I'm going to the island
I'm up here I'm up here everybody
man to look
springboard is where I'm at you jump on
the springboard and I'm flying straight
to the island
island is in the middle everybody's
gonna be there ready to get it on oh
yeah
this this this is this is heavy beef
oh
dude which is gonna be fighting up here
take the zip line up
what's that everybody's coming up here
so be ready to fight
it's gonna be the part of your life
have your guns Greek make sure you check
all the load and reload
as soon as you see somebody climbing up
on the zip line get ready to bust pause
that's good up here too
good [__] going man we're gonna get some
good stuff
that's real nice of me
attic is smart he just focus on the game
when everybody else talk attic on point
foreign
[Music]
somebody might want this
uh
yeah let's get that
surprise
What's it gonna be coming for us we
gotta um
all right we're in a good spot right now
you don't want to cause no attention all
right I see where people are fighting at
yeah
[Music]
Whoever has a sniper rifle
not dirty
knock one
I don't have anything that far distance
I don't think what what do you have yeah
that your red eye could probably hit
them
so listen when we coming down off the
mountain you can fall off the edge so be
careful make sure that you take a zip
line down or the springboard down
all right all right so the island is
there closing in on us we have 28 people
left that's including ourselves
all right final 20.
seven
oh they're getting close
knocked him
someone out
steam eliminated
how you do the Stitch right here uh left
trigger
on the d-pad
like the Stitch Part we got a whole team
that's trying to throw us down
yeah let them have it yeah
he bleed out nothing's coming up
yo watch out now you got people that's
behind us now this is I'm gonna show
y'all the springboard that we're gonna
take when we leaving
I see one I'm taking I'm jumping
straight off there's a springboard right
here yeah we doing that now right not
now
we're gonna let it close in a little bit
more we got 13 people including
ourselves
we have a team that's behind us
we have a team that's fighting in front
of us
I'm a mark where we're gonna go
but the circle is going this way
all right so we going this way
it's starting to move in now let's go I
Mark where we going
let's hit it
terrified all right you have a whole
team that's down in front of us
I'm on them oh yeah yeah
behind us behind us
oh oh knocked him won't you knock
everybody stop behind us
oh beef beef
yeah once you knock them don't worry
about them
stop come here get out of that blue that
blue that's the rocket play point what
about how do I get out the blue
just run the slide
we're shooting at her getting up
okay
dropped him oh I'm going to y'all okay
drop Tim team out
seven left
that means three left over here guys
keep that in mind the circle is over
here
yeah whoa kick it
start moving your way back to attic the
circle's about to start closing
okay
I'm on the very edge of the
going to you now but he hit you in the
um the bad spot nah the circle is
supposed to go that way but it's not
looking right the circle is like a weird
attic thumbs up it's moving now okay
well let's just keep keep looking at it
oh no it's moving back
right no it's moving away from me it's
readjusting this the circle is
readjusting all right watch oh
somebody's shaping
back behind us
he over there he over there
take them out this is what I get here
the house
[Applause]
[Laughter]
return to the lobby
I gotta get ready to burn because I got
the podcast tonight I got a Lord's
minute at seven I gotta do that and I
gotta do tonight and I did care Sanchez
I did what you want for full day
so I'll talk to you guys later we're
gonna end the podcast uh let me see Yo
good stuff y'all
four times
okay wandering Dutch actually let's go
back over there Jamaican gamer man go
over there he's streaming he puts in a
lot of work go over there and give him
some love you guys uh tell them tell
them that IOP sent you you guys in the
eye loss but never play Dusty Lewis I
play Destiny all the time